leoni
[Musique]
avec nous pour en parler ce soir
philippe karsenty porte-parole de droite
pour la france soutien d'eric zemmour
est membre du parti l'est républicain
ancien maire adjoint de
neuilly-sur-seine bonsoir philippe
karsenty merci d'être avec nous à vos
côtés valérie de bord oratrice de la
cellule riposte de valérie pécresse
candidate dont évidemment elle valérie
pécresse les républicains à la
présidentielle 2022 bonsoir à vous et
merci d'être là philippe karsenty c'est
une véritable étape dans la campagne
d'eric zemmour ce coup de fil très
médiatisée entre donald trump est
lui-même c'est une étape supplémentaire
vous savez j'étais porte parole de
donald trump en france lors de la
dernière campagne présidentielle
américaine porte parole du parti
républicain américain aussi je reste
donc membre de l air malgré tout je vote
eric zemmour et choisir exe moore
c'est une évolution naturelle
les gens de notre équipe nous avons tous
beaucoup de respect pour valérie
pécresse
simplement on pense que ça n'est pas la
bonne candidate si on pense
qu'aujourd'hui
vous savez je m'amuse souvent parce que
j'ai entendu eric zemmour parler de
valérie pécresse comme la candidate de
20h02 et moi j'ai envie de dire j'ai
l'impression que les élèves vont plutôt
être les 20 02 c'est à dire les 20
février je pense que dimanche prochain
quand les gens de l air vont voir les
résultats des sondages et vont
comprendre à quel point il ya eu un
crash dimanche dernier je pense que les
basculement vers eric zemmour vont être
assez important c'est vrai qu'à vous
même vous pourriez faire l'objet d'un
débat effectivement cette porosité entre
les républicains et le parti recomptait
inquiète en tout cas eric zemmour alors
ce soir c'est vrai qu'on va se
concentrer même si on a parlé d' un
dernier sondage qui est paru ce soir
évidemment à la fin de ce débat phare
est concentré sur ce coup de fil vous
verrez read more quel regard vous portez
sur cet échange entre l'ancien président
américain et eric zemmour au sein des
des républicains parce que c'est vrai
que ce n'est pas rien ça dit quelque
chose
qui pour moi donald trump si je suis
quelqu'un d'assez peu bien élevé qui ait
un rapport aux femmes as exécrable qui
aujourd'hui est sous le coup d'une
procédure par rapport à ce qui s'est
passé au capitole tu passes certaine ce
soit un exemple de démocratie
aujourd'hui pour notre pays et
notre interlocuteur aujourd'hui lui même
sur fox news s'est fait couper la parole
parce qu'il estimait que l'attentât à
notre dame était un complot donc je
crois qu'on est un peu dans un autre
monde qui est le monde des gens qui
croient qu'il ya des complots partout
qui les agite un petit peu de toutes
parts et qui aujourd'hui sans sang dans
l'organisme
je ne suis pas certaine que ce soit le
climat nécessaire pour la france et je
ne suis pas certaine que c'est ce que
souhaitent les français donc
franchement un tout petit épiphénomène
fait faire semblant pour rappeler une
chose vous avez parlé d'attentât de
notre dame j'ai jamais dit qu'il y avait
un attentat c'est vous qui le dites je
dis simplement que je mettais en non
vous avez parlé d'attentât vrai dit il y
avait un attentat à notre dame qui
composent les jamais dit qu'il avait un
complot j'ai simplement dit quand les
médias ont tous dit unanimement on sait
déjà que c'est un accident est pas un
acte criminel j'ai dit alors que
l'église était encore en train de brûler
j'ai tout simplement dit attendons de
voir les résultats et vous avez vous
même parlé d'attentât moi je n'ai pas
encore parlé d'attentât non monsieur
vous avez très précisément dit c'est
notre 11 novembre à nous c'est à ce
moment-là ramenons le 11 novembre vous
trompez c'est l'ensemble novembre c'est
l'armistice en septembre est depuis ses
prédécesseurs des relais battante par
les condamnés c'est à ce moment là que
le journaliste de fox news qui est
plutôt une chaîne proche de monsieur
tram faux ce que j'en sais on
connaissait beaux-arts n'en tenez vous
aggravez savoir en nous indiquant que
c'était des propos que vous ne pouviez
pas allégué de cette façon et que si
vous aviez des informations il fallait
les données ou alors il fallait vous
taire les sifflets de votre propos c'est
le dire en tout cas ce soir chez les
républicains deux côtés de valérie
pécresse en gros donat pas très crédible
permet votre ce n'est pas la personne et
n'est pas très crédible
je me reprends pour vous aujourd'hui
c'est de dire si on se fie bien votre
idée de la preuve n'est pas quelqu'un de
fréquentable et finalement on s'est
plutôt contreproductif pour eric zemmour
c'est ce que vous nous l'ont dit avant
de repasser la part lors on voit ce que
je vous dis c'est qu'aujourd'hui
monsieur donald trump est sous le coup
d'une procédure de la part du congrès
américain par rapport à ce qui s'est
passé au capitole ça c'est une réalité
que c'est aussi quelqu'un qui a tenu des
propos qui sont quand même aux confins
du machisme et de l'impolitesse
donc voilà après si c'est un modèle pour
monsieur zemmour bien qu'il assume c'est
vrai que lui même a tient des propos
vis-à-vis des femmes qui sont
particulièrement misogyne donc je vais
vous comprendrez ce niveau là jusqu'à un
demi verre mais pense c'est moi ce qui
m'ennuie c'est que je reste un membre et
l'air et je me souviens que le dernier
président ait l'air c'est nicolas
sarkozy et nicolas sarkozy il n'est pas
seulement sous le coup de la justice me
lahaie 2-4-2 condamnation à de la prison
ferme ça c'est quand même quelque chose
d'étonnant et fin quand je pense qu'on
n'ose critiquer donald trump quand on
sait qui on a en france et qui ont eu
comme président a l'air c'est quand même
incroyable donc je franchement rester
sur votre ligne
arrêtez d'attaquer uniquement sur les
personnes on a simplement un président
donald trump qui était vraiment je
dirais sur la ligne politique de la
droite française exactement sur ce
politique et ce qu'est ce qui s'est
passé c'est que malheureusement à
l'époque lr a soutenu le parti démocrate
regardez ce qu'est le parti démocrate
savez je vous dire une chose valérie
pécresse ne fera probablement pas mieux
café hillary clinton elle continuera à
jouer la carte du du soi-disant du mou
de la misogynie etc c'est ridicule elle
s'est crashée en direct c'est une femme
qui est respectable mais qui s'est
crashé en direct devant tout le monde
aujourd'hui vous êtes encore là moi je
pense que le 20 février vous serez
peut-être déjà chez emmanuel macron en
tout cas mon ami de bord la réponse
moi j'aime bien en fait les espèces de
thons incantatoire d'un monsieur qui
écrit quand même des livres avec renaud
camus oui je sais même pas comment il
s'appelle
en attendant que la chaîne 2010 cette
dernière chanson de granby 707 dans la
publicité on est très bien de quelqu'un
aussi qu' effectivement tient des propos
parfaitement complotistes enfin s'il
voulait le crédit revient de complot
n'était pas d'amis la dre placement est
une réalité sortent sans un solide sens
sortez de votre sortait deux petites
semaines
valérie pécresse en parle maintenant
valérie pécresse a dit qu'il n'y avait
pas de grand complet a annoncé qu'elle a
dit mais vous dites vous renvoie dans
l'aude et les voix de 500 ça me fait de
la peine parce que c'est ma famille
politique et vous savez ce qui est
étonnant monsieur mais vraiment très
étonnant qui est d'ailleurs de mon point
de vue aux confins de la schizophrénie
c'est que quand on soutient eric zemmour
et qu'on prétend est toujours haut et
l'air c'est comme particulièrement
bizarre particulièrement bizarre donc un
moment dans la vie il faut savoir
trancher peut-être est-ce votre problème
donc où vous êtes chez monsieur zemmour
ou vous êtes chez les républicains mais
vous n'êtes pas chez les 2 5 ce n'est
pas possible voilà pourquoi je voyage je
suis fier des résultats j'ai encore reçu
mon courrier aujourd'hui non mais on ne
demande qu'à farceur et je vous dis on
assure que jeudi larry pécresse je
reçois en faire c'est une posture du
directeur gérant du pouvoir pour ça veut
dire cette lettre c'est uniquement pour
pouvoir brandir cette laisse c'est
uniquement pour pouvoir vous en targuer
et c'est uniquement pour en faire une
publicité qu'il parfaitement excusez moi
mais indigente donc très sincèrement ça
n'est pas très intéressant tout ça n'est
pas très intéressant ce qui est
important aujourd'hui c'est le projet
que porte valérie pécresse pour les
français qui est un projet pour tous les
français qui est un projet qui est sûr
de chien est décédé moi je me suis
régalé sur les munitions explosent à la
raison va vous réinviter pour un autre
débat mais tout de même sans ce coup de
fil logique c'est reconquête évidemment
vous avez beaucoup
allègrement communiqué c'est pas membre
domi
qui soutient la mémoire c'est vrai
que là dessus quand il ya eu un sondage
qui a été effectué auprès des
sympathisants lr on s'est aperçu que si
eric zemmour avait participé la primaire
il aurait gagné à 44% au premier tour
alors de live de la première d'eric
c'est pardonnez-moi
exceptionnel soutien d'eric zemmour
allègrement communiqué voilà les équipes
ont décrit ce coup de fil on est
chaleureux est ce que vous êtes certain
effectivement que cela cela va servir le
candidat que vous soutenez eric gellé
vous savez moi j'étais en fleuret il ya
deux semaines et j'étais avec john
junior le fils de donald trump et sa
femme kim gulf oil on a parlé un petit
peu oui je pense que c'est important
fait important pour le pauvre pour pour
eric zemmour qu'il reçoive je dirais le
soutien de dirigeants dirigeants
mondiaux qui ont eu un impact
extrêmement positif sur la politique
mondiale contrairement à d'autres quand
on voit ce qui est est ce que l'état du
monde aurait eu avec joe biden avec la
guerre aux portes de l'europe avec la
guerre en afghanistan avec le bazar
absolument par tout le monde je pense
qu'avec donald trump on avait un monde
qui était bien mieux tenus alors c'est
sûr que vous si vraiment vous allez
véritablement du côté des manuels
raconte ce qui me semblait être le cas
très prochainement c'est sûr que vous
préférez joe biden alors on a interrogé
1 aux téléspectateurs coup de pouce ou
ou coup d'épée dans l'eau regarder ses
réponses un instant qu'ils vont
s'afficher jeanne avoir le soutien de
tram n'est pas une bonne chose c'est une
erreur monumentale
un autre télégramme peut-être mathieu
zemmour trump ont toujours eu le même
combat les médias s'acharnent contre eux
alors c'est vrai que ça rejoint le
communiqué officiel de d'eric zemmour
sur les points communs notamment c'est
un axe qui va aider votre candidat selon
vous le candidat de l'ump le candidat
anti élites de montres
vous avez la vérité journalistes vous
mais vous avez mais savez vous avez la
bien pensante ici il a passé vingt ans à
ce même plus 30 ans à se battre contre
tout simplement ce politiquement correct
outre ces mensonges contre toute cette
propagande qu'on avait moi je me
souviens encore un je me souviens encore
de nicolas sarkozy à l'époque qui appelé
barack obama son copain je me souviens
encore de la 2d des verts qui ont passé
leur temps à soutenir à soutenir les
démocrates aux états unis alors que la
famille politique la plus proche des
républicains français de la droite
française du rpr français s'est
naturellement les républicains
américains messine trump a dit je
souhaite que l'amérique reste l'amérique
et zemmour dit je souhaite que la france
reste la france c'est parfait ça va
parfaitement va l'élite de bord sur
cette taxe un ces points de ressemblance
notamment le candidat anti élites ça
vous fait peur justement ça du côté de
chez valérie pécresse ça lui manque
peut-être un petit peu justement d'être
juste un élément par rapport à un
monsieur 30 monsieur zemmour se
revendique matin midi et soir
gaulliste qui est parfaitement inexact
mais monsieur trump sont moins qu'on
puisse dire c'est que sa politique elle
n'aurait pas été du tout apprécié par le
général de gaulle un homme qui s'est
replié complètement sur lui même qui a
replié complètement son pays sur
lui-même tiens bon la la parenthèse par
rapport à votre question
non enfin si vous voulez monsieur
zemmour se revendique du soutien de
cette robe est grand bien lui fasse si
vous voulez ça rejoint complètement ce
que je disais précédemment je précise
pardonnez moi de vous couper mais c'est
important selon le parisien donald trump
a refusé d'apporter un soutien à eric
zemmour maintenant ils analysent gars
y'a t'il at il précisé donc ça qui a pas
de soutien officiel maintenant mais mais
mais si vous voulez c'est cette mousse
vous l'avez dit d'ailleurs vous même
dans un sourire c'est cette mousse en
fait que que les amis de monsieur
zemmour et notre interlocuteur qui
manifestement rêverait de vivre aux
états unis font autour de ce lac qui
prête à sourire ce qui est important
aujourd'hui ce sont les problèmes des
français ce qui est important
aujourd'hui c'est les solutions qui
peuvent être apportées et l'intérêt en
fait de valérie pécresse sait que c'est
quelqu'un qui aujourd'hui un bilan
derrière être monsieur zemmour il a le
bilan de 30 ans de chroniques c'est à
dire de personnes qui a parlé voulait
d'avoir parlé aussi voté ces villes
françois mitterrand dont quatre sont
légales au sommet entre les deux ya
aussi parlé de françois qui a voté pour
françois mitterrand fin c'est faux quand
même un moment faut assumer ça aussi il
a voté pour françois mitterrand c'est à
dire que tout ce déclin qu'aujourd'hui
vous êtes en train de dénoncer il y à
participer c'est un point qu'il faut
quand même relevé je vais ensuite
valérie pécresse qui est quelqu'un qui a
c'est et qui fera alors je ne vous avais
dit vous avez raison à 18 ans il a voté
pour pour françois mitterrand je trouve
ça nul ridicule pas bien du tout voilà
moi je n'ai pas voté pour françois mi
temps je n'ai jamais voté pour un
françois mi temps je n'ai jamais voté à
gauche il ya aucun problème là-dessus
tout simplement je dis quand on regarde
le aujourd'hui les projets que propose
eric zemmour et valérie pécresse si on a
vraiment au fond de soi je dirais à
coeur la france enfin je veux dire on
est obligé de manger pencher vers eric
zemmour valérie pécresse s'est vraiment
c'est un clown d' emmanuel macron en
moins bien aujourd'hui mais j'ai encore
envie je crois que vous dites ça c'est
une contrainte et non vous ne comprenez
pas noir mais je compte non mais je
comprends pas ce que pour vous c'est
électoraliste donc non évidemment c'est
votre robinet bien sûr que si votre
objectif c'est de le faire croire et et
d'ailleurs vous en la matière le
meilleur allié des miels macro parce que
et le maquereau essaye d'installer ce
duel alors qu'il sait très bien que les
adhésifs à ce que montre un sondage qui
va vous intéresse alors j'ai une
question est une question on ne fait pas
le coup de thibout qui vous voterez au
deuxième tour c'est complètement
ridicule et bien moi dont vous rêvez
vous allez aujourd'hui vous allez
aujourd'hui de façon extrêmement clair
être le meilleur allié des macros or
toutes les personnes qui nous regardent
qu'ils veulent qu emmanuel macron ne
soit plus président de la république
tantôt la seule solution c'est de voter
pour valérie garder mois en juin du
second tour la seule qui soit en
capacité en très claire elle est
incapable de passer le premier tour et
moi mais là ce
qu'on arrive à la fin mais je lui ai
alors c'est un sondage qu'on attendait
c'est pour ça que j'insiste pour me
montrer peu s'il va certainement vous
faire plaisir philippe karsenty sondages
après le zénith évidemment on parlait de
céline qui se pensent bas voilà
aujourd'hui en tout cas selon harris
interactive emmanuel macron caracole
toujours en tête car 25% au premier tour
marine le pen deuxième 17 ennemis et
vient 3e éric zemmour 14 et demi juste
devant valérie pécresse
valérie de bord ces cétacés ce que vous
craignez ou voilà ce n'est qu'un sondage
et après tout vous ne vous l'avais dit
avec grandeur d'âme c'est selon harris
si vous prenez opinionway elle est à 16
et les devants et c'est elle qui est au
deuxième tour donc on voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui les choses ne sont pas
figées pour une raison assez simple mm
macro n'est toujours pas candidat et
tant qu'il n'est pas candidat eh bien
les choses ne sont pas posées et n'en
déplaise
à
mesure nous sommes aujourd'hui dans une
dynamique où valérie pécresse un
programme qui est diamétralement opposé
à celui des mêmes accroc puisque très
clairement elle veut mettre en place la
république des territoires très valorisé
le travail je vais vous répondre
la fin des paradis voilà
mon tour macron pécresse je vote très
clairement pécresse en cas de second
tour macron zemmour qui voter pour qui
voter vous mais moi je voterais pour
valérie pécresse tendance croyez vous
voyez la différence la différence entre
les vrais gens de droite et ceux qui
sont prêts à aller à 20h00
ou dit vous irez chez lui vous irez le
troc ascom du clip puisque je désirais
le sait comme tous ses camarades vous
[Musique]
bien ce sera bonne merci en tout cas on
vous avez draps pour des débats de fond
en tout cas sur les deux programmes
merci philippe karsenty d'être venu
merci à velenje de bord d'avoir été là
également merci à vous deux